good everyone here we are with the grandmaster
the experience of playing 960
super interesting is not new for
everyone for me too but positions are given
that is interesting to say with
enough room for creativity
we are thinking that it should be
more tiring than playing fast
Normally, you don't have to
create from the beginning, of course, you have to
start thinking about the players,
well, not from 1, because you prepare a
little, but the same from 2 or 3, the
player, the players, have to
start working hard,
and well, too.  you have to play it at
least what I am doing is playing a
little by intuition I think that
everyone very difficult
with this calculation of those played
but it has been years
we were watching just in this position
for example he prepared us with everything for
the  because I notice that it's traveling the
same opening is moving
right before this fun because it's kind of
easy to know what I was leaving they
're playing  to the couple
here we are going at the beginning creating
the theory seeing from this game that
position today seemed to me like
less dynamic a little slower
than yesterday I don't know if because they are with me and
well there were some
quite forced variants of the  very
complicated start that of the delivery but with 11
4 547 today's maybe a little more more
normal exposure to oviedo
in defended in red was quite easy
also the pieces were not so bad
so yes I think it can't be
quite quite reasonable  or quite
similar to the traditional beef ones and
how is your subway seeing and it has been a
difficult day and well complicated
the rival was quite hard but I did think that I had a
good chance I am in fact I always had good
positions the two positions
that I lost in a moment  I was fine in
fact in the first one of course when it came
to putting the board there are
complications with a rook for hc and
if we really in this position
it seemed to us that  ea the men were
being very optimistic because it doesn't seem
good I was playing rather for my
time and practical it seems very good to me I
also said that he bought work for 316
and well 6
my original idea was they gave for 4
and I think he doesn't care  al without
many problems because he changed the queens
rook h 8
efe 72 record of 82 replaces 8
rook of 1%
that is the key 0 0
if it fits bridge five rooks c 2 and I think
I will have enough against the
game and 45
but all misgivings  reiche 3-6 and 6-3
5 caballé 5 we seemed super interesting
and with chances to win also damages 7
and here well I was also impractical
press almost a minute
efe 8 original video to play
flexible kings also to have a bull h 8
world
yes  we looked at this play
gentlemen I think they were gentlemen so
that it is not final 08 we did not know very
well with a play
ef 83 vf 7 shinobi rook of 6 thinking
that it even wins but I suppose that the
position here is but constant play it
for me they don't eat 42 and you can eat
the problem is that it doesn't threaten anything
but,
gentleman, we ladies give ourselves
because of 3 434
and as it was necessary for that, he couldn't
take action
- with the pure one when I come give me one
serve  and tables for that
h two horses for effectors
well the
same I do
n't know if the mother I don't know if more than one
and well then there are dangers horses
of 6 commented threats
[Music]
and well because the end now I'm very
well
you can't eat it
of one
but I didn't have time and
this would be the play ends in three
sets today at ef 76
this game is nice but the
time we have been following a lot that
has been fair also
had a fairly equal position now
yes quite normal it is at 6  after
63 it does not seem like a little pressure to
ivo that that 5 horses of 5 gravel out of
4 we have been
with the stalls and
perhaps instead of d
like that the proposal they make with yes perhaps
to 5 a little more active let's say the
work  organize  do the 5 even
social 4 4 7 5 it
looks like you have some good yes i
guess now that's why it's not very
good
but it was very impractical I had a two
minute head start at the time and it's
time consuming sometimes it happens what you
want is to tune  and you leave yourself there because
the weather is good, there are two days
left, which is going to be very important in the
two that are left of fast the two
terminals because in the end they are worth double s
it is not good enough luis you were
in the rapids a month ago and he is also
here  in good condition and always a tournament
of matches that is quite complicated, but
well, it
is interesting and apart from all this, it
is quite good if we were just
starting out, but if it has had,
people have liked it, we are
improving a little more,
now you can take a look, but if it is  you
throw leinier dotcom and there they have a good
video of white meat of wool and decided
all kinds of opening with half a game
the classic interesting videos to
improve well
nothing have a lot of luck tomorrow  na
also great it will be said that we are
giving
and well, we are going to take a
look at the classification and we will
say goodbye until tomorrow as we see these
sticks
there is a little
more loose today we really know that
even schering almost a little out of
respect we do not  he wanted to tighten that end
after the hang to
arrive and he is winning 48 topálov nakamura
and the tie at 6
and the one who is untreatable
the truth is that it is the unit that is
a genius it seems to me that I understand all
the positions too